today we're going to do a deep dive into
this exam paper that covers a variety of
topics within mathematics extension 2.
we're going to have a look at mechanics
vectors bit of proof all kinds of
different things so let's get stuck into
this and we're also going to try and
highlight some of the key errors that
were made or are likely to made when
looking at these questions as well as
where appropriate multiple ways of
solving each problem so let's have a
look at question 1a
a particle moving in a straight line
obeys this particular equation that is
provided here which i'm going to
highlight because obviously
we're going to need to use this in a
second where x is its displacement from
the origin in meters and v is its
velocity in meters per second okay so
we've got some units there that's handy
what is the question actually asking of
us part one show that the particle is
moving in simple harmonic motion and
then subsequently determine the interval
that the particle moves through and the
maximum speed
of the particle all right so let's just
make note of that before we go any
further um what we want to do is first
this is kind of like a proof question
right so we're not trying to find a
result in part one we're just trying to
show that this is actually
simple harmonic motion this v squared
equation that we've got here and then
also we are looking for in part two two
separate things um number one the
interval so i guess you could say that's
like the domain like where can this
particle move between because simple
harmonic motion has two extremes that
you're going to be going back and forth
and back and forth and then finally
we're looking for a maximum speed how
fast can the particle go
all right so that's uh what we need to
do let's have a look at what was this
question
one part a
let's look at part one first
so as we already flagged we're going to
need to work with this equation that's
given to us it's kind of the only piece
of information that will decide for us
whether this is going to be simple
motion or not and you can see right
there i think that's just big enough for
for us to read it's v squared equals 9
outside of 5 plus
4x minus x squared so this is where we
can start where are we going to go
well the key characteristic of simple
harmonic motion that we know about the
way that we define simple harmonization
from the beginning is that the
acceleration that's acting on an object
under super harmonic motion is always
opposite to
um the direction of the displacement
right so whichever way if you're like
moving to the left your um
acceleration is going to be to the right
and vice versa if you're on the right
then it's going to go to the left and so
that's that sort of restoring force
that's always pushing you back towards
the center in proportion to how far you
are from the center the further away you
are the more it pushes you back that's
what produces simple hormone immersion
so i need to get from this equation
which is about v squared into something
that tells me about acceleration now
there are a few different ways to do
this
but certainly the most clear and obvious
way is to say one of the ways that we
can
state acceleration we can say what was i
using orange right we can say that x
double dot can be written as
the derivative with respect to x
of half v squared this was a result that
we got out of a couple of uses of the
chain rule if you remember that
result so because i've got this half v
squared appearing in this particular way
of you know articulating or expressing
acceleration
it makes it very easy to go from this v
squared up into that result okay
um there are other ways you might try
and go about it but they're not going to
be very helpful i'll come back to that
in a moment let's do this approach and
see how it works
so for starters i need a half v squared
not a v squared in this so i'm just
going to divide both sides by 2.
this term here remains unchanged in the
brackets there that's great and now i'm
going to differentiate with respect to x
so i get the derivative of half v
squared
with respect to x
and then on the right hand side what am
i going to get well i'll leave that
constant coefficient out the front it
doesn't really affect things and then
when i have a look at what's inside the
brackets that 5 is a constant doesn't
affect the gradient at all that 4x is
going to differentiate down into 4 and
that minus x squared is going to
differentiate into minus 2x so from
there you can see oh look this is great
i've got a factor of a half out here
that can go into the brackets so that's
going to leave me with
9 on the outside and then 2 minus x on
the inside and the reason why you might
recall we introduced this is because
that's a way of articulating or
expressing acceleration so there's x
double dot
now what was i saying before about like
the definition of simple harmonic motion
in simple harmonic motion
x double dot the acceleration should be
opposed so that's what the negative sign
is for some constant
multiply by whichever direction of
displacement you are in right so you can
see if displacement is positive then
this negative sign is going to make
acceleration negative and vice versa so
i'm looking for something like that here
right you can see it's not difficult to
take a minus sign out the front
that 9 i can just leave that that's my n
squared i'll just write that as 9 and
then having taken a minus sign out
i can a factor of minus 1 i should say i
can write that as x minus 2. and we're
done you can see it's not exactly the
same as this but that's because it's off
by a constant which means there's been a
shift the center of motion unlike in
this situation which would be x 0 the
center of motion here is going to be x
equals 2 and that's all there is to it
okay
so i can say off of this therefore this
is simple harmonic motion i don't need
to prove any more
now i mentioned before there are other
ways to go about this and this is
problematic for students who attempted
it when some students look and they say
oh this is an acceleration sorry this is
a velocity equation and i need to get to
acceleration some students thought well
the way to get from velocity to this you
know out of here they might have gotten
confused with displacement so they tried
to integrate right
in fact here you've got to differentiate
but some students would have
differentiated incorrectly because they
think oh acceleration can also be
written as dv on dt it's the change in
velocity with respect to time the reason
why that's problematic is because you
haven't been given an expression here on
the right hand side with respect to time
so trying to differentiate that with
respect to t not very useful for you
also there were a few arithmetic errors
that could creep in as you went through
these lines of working but if you had
a clear path charted through the
question it generally wasn't too
difficult
okay so that was part one i've just
shown that simple harmonic motion